(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula nós vamos aprender os termos muito
comuns nos leilões.
Quais são esses termos?
Primeira praça, segunda praça, incremento, lance automático, lance
condicional e proposta.
Começando pela primeira e segunda praça.
O que significa falar que um bem vai
ser levado em primeira e em segunda praça
num leilão judicial?
No leilão judicial, o juiz vai determinar que
ocorram duas tentativas de venda daquele imóvel, exatamente
a primeira praça e depois a segunda praça.
Na primeira praça, no leilão judicial, vai ser
usado o valor da avaliação judicial.
O que é isso?
Quando um juiz determina um leilão de um
imóvel, ele vai precisar saber qual é o
valor de mercado daquele imóvel, porque é exatamente
esse valor de mercado que vai ser o
valor da primeira praça.
Via de regra, isso não é feito pelas
partes.
Ocorre uma única exceção se as duas partes,
credor e devedor, chegarem a um consenso sobre
o valor de mercado do bem.
Mas a regra é que esse valor seja
determinado através de uma avaliação judicial.
Essa avaliação judicial pode ser feita por um
oficial de justiça ou ela pode ser feita
por um perito judicial.
E aí, na maioria dos casos, se for
um perito, vai ser por um arquiteto ou
um engenheiro.
Então, quando ocorrer essa avaliação judicial, vai ser
determinado o valor de mercado daquele imóvel e
é esse valor que vai ser usado na
primeira praça do leilão.
Já na segunda praça, vai ser oferecido um
percentual de desconto sobre esse valor da avaliação
do imóvel.
E esse percentual de desconto, via de regra,
pode chegar em até 50%.
Esse percentual vai ser determinado pelo juiz e
o juiz vai falar especificamente naquele caso se
vai incidir um desconto de 20%, 40%
ou 50% naquele leilão.
E aí, esse vai ser o valor da
segunda praça.
A regra é que esse desconto possa ser
de 50%.
Mas a gente vai estudar que existe uma
exceção que é relativa aos leilões da Justiça
do Trabalho.
Então, a gente vai estudar especificamente no módulo
3, vai ter uma aula especial para isso,
que nos leilões da Justiça do Trabalho, é
possível que seja oferecido um desconto maior do
que 50%.
É normal que a gente encontre imóvel sendo
leiloado pela Justiça do Trabalho por 35%, 40
% do seu valor de avaliação.
Como é que funciona no leilão ex-prejudicial?
No leilão ex-prejudicial, também vão ocorrer duas
tentativas de tentar vender aquele imóvel em leilão.
A lei chama de primeiro e segundo leilão,
mas, popularmente, os leiloeiros também utilizam a denominação
de primeira praça e segunda praça, porque é
essa denominação que é utilizada no leilão judicial.
Então, para não confundir as pessoas, fica tudo
com o mesmo nome, primeira praça e segunda
praça.
Na primeira tentativa de vender um imóvel em
leilão ex-prejudicial, a primeira praça, o imóvel
vai pelo valor que o próprio contrato de
alienação fiduciária estipulou para caso acontecesse um leilão.
Ou seja, um dos requisitos de um contrato
de alienação fiduciária é exatamente essa cláusula.
Então, o próprio contrato deve falar qual vai
ser o valor utilizado para aquele imóvel que
foi dado em garantia para o pagamento de
uma dívida, caso aconteça um leilão.
E esse valor vai ser o valor da
primeira praça.
Existe uma exceção, que é sobre o valor
do ITBI do imóvel.
ITBI é o imposto municipal e a gente
vai ter uma aula específica sobre ITBI no
último módulo.
Mas já vou adiantar que por ser um
imposto municipal, as prefeituras calculam o chamado valor
venal daquele imóvel.
E esse valor venal vai ser o valor
usado para calcular o ITBI, que é o
Imposto de Transmissão de Bens Imóveis entre Pessoas
Vivas.
Então, se o valor venal calculado pela prefeitura
for superior ao valor estipulado no contrato de
alienação fiduciária, vai ser utilizado em primeira praça
o valor venal para fins de ITBI.
Então, fique com isso em sua mente.
Ou vai ser usado na primeira praça do
leilão excrediticial o valor que o próprio contrato
de alienação fiduciária estipulou para caso acontecesse um
leilão, ou vai ser utilizado o valor venal
para fins de ITBI que a prefeitura do
município onde fica localizado aquele imóvel calculou para
aquele determinado imóvel, o que for maior nesse
caso.
Já em segunda praça, o imóvel vai ser
oferecido por um valor mínimo que pelo menos
pague a dívida mais os encargos que incidam
sobre aquele imóvel.
Então, se o valor da dívida em encargos
for inferior ao valor do próprio imóvel, o
valor utilizado na primeira praça, esse vai ser
o valor da segunda praça.
Então, é comum que na segunda praça de
um leilão excrediticial, o imóvel seja oferecido com
desconto, exatamente porque o valor da dívida mais
os encargos vai ser inferior ao próprio valor
do imóvel.
O incremento, o que seria o incremento?
O incremento é um acréscimo mínimo que deve
ser ofertado em relação ao lance anterior.
Então, vamos entender como é que funciona.
Existe um valor mínimo de primeira e segunda
praça e esse valor deve ser respeitado.
Você só vai conseguir oferecer um valor inicial
que seja no mínimo por esse lance mínimo
estipulado, que a gente acabou de estudar quais
são os valores mínimos de primeira e segunda
praça para leilão judicial e de primeira e
segunda praça para leilão excrediticial.
Então, ocorre um lance mínimo e todos os
lances subsequentes vão ter que observar pelo menos
o incremento que ficou estipulado no edital.
Esse incremento é estipulado pelo próprio leiloeiro e
ele tem uma relação com o valor do
próprio imóvel que está sendo oferecido em leilão.
Quando a gente tem um leilão de um
imóvel mais popular, é normal que esse incremento
ele seja menor, que ele fique perto de
R$ 1.000, R$ 2.000.
Quando a gente tem um imóvel muito caro,
um imóvel muito luxuoso, pode ser que esse
incremento fique em R$ 50.000 e
aí vai depender de cada edital, você vai
ter que verificar naquele seu caso específico qual
é o valor do incremento que está incidindo
naquele leilão.
Então vamos lá, primeiro lance, pelo lance mínimo.
Segundo lance, ele vai ter que respeitar pelo
menos esse valor mínimo de incremento.
Agora, é importante que você saiba que você
não precisa ficar reescrito ao valor de incremento.
Vamos aqui um exemplo então, vamos supor que
a gente tem um imóvel que o lance
mínimo era de R$ 150.000, o
incremento é de R$ 5.000. Então
alguém foi lá, ofertou o lance mínimo, R
$ 150.000. Se outra pessoa quiser ofertar
um lance acima, ela vai precisar, no mínimo,
respeitar o incremento.
Como no nosso caso é um incremento de
R$ 5.000, o próximo lance viável
seria de R$ 155.000, depois R
$ 160.000, R$ 165.000, R
$ 170.000 e aí por diante.
Só que esse é um incremento mínimo, nada
impede que alguém ofereça o lance mínimo de
R$ 150.000 e o seu próximo
lance seja de R$ 165.000. Você
tem que ofertar pelo menos o incremento, você
não fica reescrito àquele valor.
Então se você já quiser fazer um lance
superior ao incremento, você pode fazer.
Qual é a finalidade de você oferecer um
lance superior ao incremento mínimo?
Isso pode ter uma finalidade em um leilão
que esteja muito concorrido.
Então vamos supor, aquele leilão que está tendo
um lance atrás do outro.
Pode ser que ao dar um lance superior
ao incremento, você já elimine a concorrência que
estava naquele leilão.
Isso aí você vai precisar observar no momento
do leilão.
Você vai precisar observar se aquele leilão está
com concorrência, se os lances estão respeitando somente
o valor do incremento, se tem alguém oferecendo
valores maiores do que o valor mínimo do
incremento e aí vai sentir e vai ver
qual é a melhor estratégia que você pode
usar ali naquele momento.
Também existe a possibilidade em um leilão judicial
de você realizar um lance automático.
Nesse lance automático, o próprio sistema do leiloeiro
realiza automaticamente os lances em nome de um
interessado, respeitando o valor máximo cadastrado e o
valor de incremento lance após lance.
Então vamos supor, nesse nosso mesmo exemplo de
um imóvel sendo oferecido pelo preço mínimo de
150 mil reais.
Você fez lá seu estudo e você determinou
que o valor máximo que você pode oferecer
naquele determinado leilão é 180 mil reais.
Então você quer cadastrar um lance automático.
Alguém foi lá e deu 150 mil reais
e você colocou seu lance automático como 180.
O leiloeiro vai fazer o procedimento sozinho para
você e seu nome.
Se o incremento for de 5 mil nesse
nosso caso, o próximo lance possível seria de
155 mil.
Então o leiloeiro vai realizar no seu nome
esse lance de 155 mil.
Se alguém cobrir esse seu lance de 155
mil, o próximo lance viável seria de 160.
Afinal, o incremento no nosso exemplo é de
5 mil.
Então alguém foi lá e ofereceu 160.
O leiloeiro automaticamente vai oferecer 165 mil em
seu nome.
Alguém foi lá e ofereceu 170.
O leiloeiro oferece 175 mil em seu nome.
Alguém foi lá e ofereceu 180.
O seu lance máximo era 180, ou seja,
o leiloeiro não vai mais oferecer lance automático
em seu nome.
A partir daquele momento, você deverá efetuar lances
manuais ou cadastrar outra possibilidade de lance automático
caso você faça a opção por continuar participando
daquele leilão.
Qual é a finalidade de fazer um lance
automático?
Pode ser uma boa estratégia se no momento
determinado para aquele leilão você não tiver disponibilidade
de acompanhar o leilão.
De repente pode ser que você esteja em
uma reunião de trabalho e você não possa
participar, por exemplo, e você vai lá e
cadastra seu lance automático.
Mas também pode ter uma outra finalidade.
Quando um leilão está muito concorrido, se você
cadastrar um lance automático, todas as outras pessoas
que estão participando daquele leilão vão ver que
o seu cadastro está como lance automático.
Só que não aparece para os outros concorrentes
qual foi o valor máximo que você cadastrou
em seu lance.
Então as pessoas estão vendo a informação de
lance automático no seu login, mas elas não
estão vendo qual é o valor máximo que
você está disposto a pagar naquele imóvel.
Isso tem uma pressão psicológica em quem está
concorrendo a um leilão.
Por quê?
O leilão está lá disputado e está lá
lance manual, lance manual, lance manual, lance manual.
Até aparece um lance automático.
Quando aparece um lance automático, a tendência é
que as pessoas pensem que você está muito
disposto a arrematar aquele imóvel e como elas
não sabem o valor que você está disposto
a pagar, porque o lance automático não vai
mostrar para as pessoas quanto você está disposto
a pagar, pode ser que elas considerem já
ficar de fora daquele leilão.
Porque tem gente que pensa, ah, tem alguém
com lance automático, então essa pessoa quer muito
esse imóvel.
Então não faz sentido eu ficar aqui brigando
por um imóvel que alguém quer muito, porque
existem pessoas que participam do leilão como investimento
e existem pessoas que participam do leilão como
moradia.
Quando a gente fala de moradia, qualquer percentual
de desconto, ele já passa a ser interessante,
porque se você comprar um imóvel para morar,
se ele tiver 10% de desconto, isso
já é uma grande vantagem para quem quer
essa finalidade.
Agora, se for uma finalidade de investimento, você
realmente precisa de um desconto maior para que
aquilo tenha uma viabilidade, um retorno lucrativo para
você.
Então você não sabe também qual é a
finalidade dos seus concorrentes, você não sabe se
o concorrente quer morar ou se ele quer
comprar para investimento.
E isso faz muita diferença no preço que
a pessoa está disposta a pagar.
Então pode ser que esse lance automático tenha
um fator psicológico nesse sentido.
Nada impede, por exemplo, de você cadastrar um
lance automático da seguinte forma.
O leilão está em R$175 mil, o
próximo lance viável seria de R$180 mil,
no incremento de R$5 mil.
Você está disposto a pagar no máximo R
$180 mil, ou seja, você só poderia ofertar
mais um lance.
Você pode cadastrar isso como automático e aí
vai aparecer lá para a pessoa automático.
Ela não sabe que após aquele valor, esse
é o último lance, que após aquele lance
você vai parar.
Pode ser que esse fator do lance automático
pese um pouco na escolha do seu concorrente
de continuar ofertando naquele imóvel ou não.
Saiba que existe essa possibilidade e essa possibilidade
é muito importante nos casos do leilão que
você não consegue acompanhar ali de forma presencial
no momento que o leilão está acontecendo.
Agora uma informação importante.
Você cadastrou, por exemplo, R$180 mil em
lance automático para determinado imóvel.
Você fez um lance automático de R$170
mil, o próximo lance viável, no nosso exemplo
de incremento de R$5 mil, seria R
$175 mil e ninguém ofereceu esse lance, ninguém
cobriu o seu lance.
O leilão vai encerrar por R$170 mil.
Não é porque você cadastrou um lance automático
que necessariamente o leilão vai chegar naquele seu
lance automático.
Se ninguém cobrir os seus lances anteriores, vai
encerrar pelo valor do lance normalmente não vai
ter a necessidade de chegar no seu lance
automático.
Existe o que a gente chama também de
lance condicional.
O que é o lance condicional?
O lance condicional é quando o valor ofertado
em determinado lance é inferior ao preço mínimo
de um leilão.
Existe essa possibilidade e aí essa possibilidade vai
ser enviada ao credor fiduciário, caso seja um
leilão extrajudicial, ou ao juiz que determinou um
leilão judicial.
E aí vai ficar a critério deles se
eles aceitam ou não esse lance.
O juiz pode aceitar ou não o lance,
o credor fiduciário, em sua grande maioria os
bancos, pode ou não aceitar o lance que
foi ofertado pelo valor mínimo necessário para levar
o imóvel.
E por fim existe o que a gente
chama de proposta.
A proposta nada mais é do que você
oferecer um lance respeitando a possibilidade que ficou
descrita no edital sobre parcelamento ou sobre financiamento.
Então se for por exemplo um leilão judicial,
via de regra vai ser possível o parcelamento
em até 30 vezes com no mínimo 25
% de entrada.
Quem estiver interessado em oferecer um lance de
forma parcelada vai fazer essa proposta diretamente no
site do leiloeiro, você não vai até o
juiz fazer essa proposta, você faz essa proposta
para o leiloeiro.
Nos sites dos leiloeiros vai ficar um campo
lá para você preencher essa proposta, você vai
botar quanto você quer de entrada, quantas parcelas
você quer, qual vai ser o valor da
parcela, qual vai ser a correção monetária que
vai incidir em cada parcela e vai preencher.
Então se só existirem ofertas de pagamento parcelado
ao final de um leilão judicial, o leiloeiro
vai levar ao juiz que vai decidir se
aceita ou não aquela proposta da forma como
ela foi realizada.
A mesma coisa acontece no leilão ex-prejudicial,
se ocorrer uma possibilidade de parcelamento e o
interessado em arrematar fizer uma proposta utilizando essa
possibilidade, essa proposta vai ser encaminhada ao credor
que mandou que aquele leilão acontecesse e ele
vai avaliar se aceita ou não essa proposta.
Esses são os termos que você vai encontrar
na prática em um leilão, é importante que
você saiba exatamente o que significa cada um
deles.